the ocean is a terrifying place we've
all heard the statistics more than 80 of
the ocean remains unexplored that's most
of the water covering the globe
completely unmapped and unobserved by
science it's a scary thought to dwell on
realizing that there's more water than
land on earth and the sheer expanse of
that water is so large that we've been
unable to fully explore all of it just
think there are places in the ocean that
have never been seen by a human who
knows what's down there if there was
ever a personification of fear of the
unknown the ocean could definitely be it
ancient shipwrecks sunk to the ocean
floor unknown sea creatures hiding away
from humanity and the general isolation
of the suffocating dark blue the ocean
swallows its victims with all of these
images that come to mind when thinking
about the vast and mysterious depths of
the sea and no one is more familiar with
nautical mysteries than the scp
foundation today we'll be taking a look
at scp-5007
the bass strait a wave of oceanic
anomalies fit to make any season sailor
shiver in fear the bass strait is an
area of ocean dividing tasmania and the
australian mainland it's also the
location of an unusually high amount of
disappearances sailors disappearing from
their ships fishermen leaving in the
night and never coming back even
civilians disappearing from the shores
that connect to the strait the
foundation was aware of these
disappearances since 1858 but were only
able to craft theories about what was
causing them was it an anomalous group
of interest hostile aerial entities
patrolling the skies above the strait
phenomenon associated with unidentified
flying objects what about subterranean
anomalies weather patterns or time
dilation for nearly a century the
foundation was unable to determine the
cause of the high number of
disappearances in the bath straight and
then the phenomenon suddenly revealed
itself in 1980 on a beach connected to
the strait agent tabarner an operative
of the scp foundation was vacationing
with his wife mary and his three young
children the taverner family was simply
enjoying their day when they saw what
looked like balloons in the sky they
were approaching quickly and naturally
the family moved closer what happened
next was a whirlwind and those balloons
the family were so interested in lifted
them up from the ground and carried them
away agent taverner tried to fight back
but there was nothing he could do except
report to the foundation what had
occurred and the organization responded
in full force the foundation's research
discovered that reports of ufos and
lights in the sky had coincided with
many disappearances in the strait and
that this was a pattern the search for
the four lost taverner family members
had become a large-scale investigation
into unexplained disappearances along
the bass strait and within three weeks
it was determined that these patterns
were consistent across the entirety of
the straits coastal regions some
witnesses were interviewed but the vast
majority of these abduction cases had no
witnesses whatsoever of the minimal
reports filed the foundation was told
that there were lights in the sky and
that appearance of unidentified flying
objects described as having the
appearances of balloons one such witness
interviewed was a man by the name of
alan stewart a witness who was present
during the disappearance of former
australian prime minister harold holt
whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the bass straits anomalies during the
interview steward claimed that holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim holt turned to stuart and asked him
if he could see the balloons around the
cliff stewart had no idea what holt was
talking about but holt was insistent on
seeing them he swam deeper out into the
ocean saying that they weren't normal
balloons and that there was someone
inside of them stuart and halt's family
called out for him to come to shore but
he wouldn't listen stewart tried to
rationalize what he saw next maybe it
was the current sweeping halt away but
he couldn't lie to the foundation
interviewer stewart saw holt go further
and further out into the water and
suddenly the prime minister turned
around he began swimming in the opposite
direction and he was screaming suddenly
holt was lifted from the sea and pulled
into the air by something emerging from
the clouds the foundation thanked
stewart for the interview and continued
their investigation two years later in
1982 emergency services received a large
number of calls pertaining to ufo
sightings off the coast of norman bay
victoria the foundation was quick to
respond alerting task forces and local
sites to prepare for an investigation
upon arriving to the scene they
confirmed the existence of multiple
entities that would later be documented
as scp-5007
they evacuated civilians from the area
and successfully managed to capture the
creature which was later transported to
site 40 for containment it was a sight
to behold the entity now designated
scp-5007-s1
was a cluster of human bodies fused
between a grouping of black tentacles of
varying length each tentacle was fused
to the skin it touched directly the
stomachs of the corpses were grossly
swollen and distorted to massive sizes
to hold large quantities of gases inside
the buoyancy of which the entity used to
achieve a passive flight across the
entity's surface were clusters of eyes
and bioluminescent glowing organs many
of the humanoid components of the
corpses appeared to have been removed
and misplaced across various parts of
the entity's body what's more is that
the foundation discovered that human
portions of scp-5007
appeared somewhat cognizant and aware of
their situation their vocalizations were
incoherent and barely understandable
consisting of gasping and whimpering but
the corpses were observed to implore
other individuals to approach them when
encountered
scp-5007's behavior during abduction
scenarios was documented during the
initial containment event and due to the
foundation's painstaking research a
pattern was established between all
scp-5007 encounters first the victim
would be alone or otherwise vulnerable
in a coastal location
scp-5007 haven't shown a preference for
weather be they clear or hostile skies
but they have localized all of their
activity to the bass strait in small
coastal towns beaches or boats
scp-5007 will then move towards the
shore stalking the victim before
lowering its tentacles and appendages to
grab the individual snatching them into
the sky an scp-5007
instance can even abduct multiple people
at once one event observed had eight men
from the decks of a commercial fishing
boat taken into the sky in under 15
seconds once captured
scp-5007 instances will dart across the
water at a high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where
scp-5007 took their victims became a top
priority for the foundation after
extensive witness interviews and
compiling a database of likely victims
they determined that there must be at
least 16 instances of
scp-5007 unaccounted for personnel kept
a close watch on the coastlines and
waters of the bass strait and equipped
various marine task forces with research
vessels capable of tracking any
instances if they encountered them in
1985 the foundation's research efforts
paid off and several survey teams
operating in the area reported the
sighting of an extremely large
scp-5007 instance heading towards a
coastal town a mobile task force was
sent to track the entity the team
observed the entity from afar as it
stalked a private fishing boat even from
the distance foundation personnel
recognized the likenesses of several
missing persons as faces of the corpses
of scp-5007
the task force captain had to remind his
team to keep it together claiming that
they were not people but just parts of
the specimen but everyone secretly knew
the truth the fishing vessel was a
private one occupied by a small family
the entity slowly approached and quickly
pulled a woman into the air the family
panicked and quickly tried to reach
cover for safety running into the ship's
cabin the entity ran its tentacles along
the boat until it pulled the door open
snatching another two victims the task
force was unable to help them as their
mission was to track the instance to its
origin point it was a horror to watch
the task force implanted a tracking
beacon onto the entity and quietly
followed it out to sea over the next
four hours they then discovered a large
gray reef with several shipwrecks dotted
across it thirteen
scp-5007 instances floated over the area
some holding onto the land reef with
their tentacles the entity dropped the
abductees from the fishing boat who were
coerced by the entities into diving into
a massive pool of water located in the
center of the reef one by one each
abductee was pulled below the surface by
something lurking in the pool all while
the scp-5007
instance is watched disgusted the task
force reported what they observed to the
main site and the reef would be
designated as scp-5007-a
[Music]
the foundation's analysis of the reef
led to the discovery that the rock
covering it seeped iron oxide from an
unknown source and the rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the
wrecked ships and aircraft that washed
across the shore of the reef were
covered with a dark stone the reef was
teeming with anomalous marine life
including
scp-5007 a red algae that fed upon the
freshly grown rock marine worms capable
of levitation spiders that lived in silk
retreats underneath the waterline small
fish and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp which the
foundation had previously documented as
scp-4159
in a separate investigation
scp-5007 often rested their tentacles on
the outcroppings of the reef while
inactive but what caught the
foundation's attention the most was the
giant pit located in the reef's center
unmanned exploration drones found that
it had a depth of at least 4 000 meters
and water samples taken from the pit
revealed large quantities of human dna
prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compounds that possess significant
life-preserving qualities when a being
was submerged in the compound they were
able to survive heavy injuries even when
fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
led them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived located in the back of
the book it detailed the experience of
an unknown crew member of the ship
caught in a storm it reads mosby spied
land ahead and the boy said that there
are giant balloons hanging over the
island we are all feared but there is
not we can do but beach ourselves and
hope for rescue should i be killed in
the crash i want my mage to give this
journal to my mary might know i spent my
last thinking only of her the interior
of the ship contained human remains
inside but there were less skeletons
than the foundation would expect for a
ship of its size the location of the
rest of the bodies was unknown another
event related to
scp-5007 the foundation documented
involved frederick valentick a pilot
engaged in a training flight over the
bass strait in 1978. valentick's
disappearance was marked by his latest
communication with air traffic control
when he mistook an scp-5007 instance for
an unidentified aircraft it seems like
it's stationary what i'm doing right now
is orbiting and the thing is just
orbiting on top of me also it's got a
green light and sort of metallic like
it's all shiny on the outside shortly
after this valentic's transmission was
interrupted by what was described as
metallic scraping sounds believed to be
the scp-5007
instance attacking the aircraft and
jamming its propellers with its mass
after crashing into the reef it was
believed that valentick and his aircraft
were pulled beneath the surface of the
pit just as the abductees had been prior
the foundation decided to construct a
provisional secure research facility on
the reef they named it site 40-r and
documented all returns and departures of
scp-5007
they also set up a series of containment
procedures that resulted in
scp-5007 returning with its victims 83
less often than before the site's
construction but this was short-lived in
2008 the site logged over 36 instances
returning to the reef with only two not
having any fresh abductees the
instance's origins were unknown and it
was as if they appeared out of thin air
no other monitoring post had documented
their appearance or even spotted them
before they arrived at the reef it was
years later in 2017 that the foundation
eventually was able to successfully
explore what was deep inside the pit at
the center of the reef they already knew
that there was a large entity lurking
beneath as evidenced by what happened to
the victims of scp-5007
that were later deposited inside the
pool all previous attempts to explore
the pool were met with failure as the
water pressure of the pit's depths
caused all craft to collapse due to hull
damage this time however they managed to
construct a high-tech submarine labeled
the scp-s nautilus which was capable of
diving a maximum of 13 500 meters
underwater they decided that a d-class
personnel would be trained to man the
submersible and carry out the
exploration the mission was simple the
nautilus was to dive to the bottom of
the pit and to describe the depth
readings cameras and microphones were
equipped to the vessel due to the depth
remote viewing of the footage was
impossible instead the foundation had to
physically recollect the vessel in order
to view the footage upon recovery some
of the footage suffered data corruption
but what was there shook those who
viewed it to their core the footage
showed the d-classes experience going
deeper inside the pit at first it seemed
ordinary the trench had a number of
rocky outcroppings dotted with black
yellow vines growing along the walls
also present were various marine life
forms such as the spiders or the fish
going deeper the sub observed an
scp-5007 instance clinging to an
outcropping several tendrils emerging
from the pit's depths were wrapped
around the instance and holding on to
the entity as if it were feeding from it
another 16 scp-5007
instances were seen resting along the
walls each clinging to the outcropping
as the sub went deeper the d-class
remarked that there were dozens of plane
and shipwrecks but also well over a
hundred
scp-5007 entities most of them were held
there by the black tendrils the d-class
as the sub went even deeper began
noticing human remains no short amount
of them either deep into the pit there
was a large mass of human remains
covering the entirety of the pit bodies
crushed and drained of blood but still
possessing intact eyes each individual
was still alive kept preserved by the
life-sustaining compounds found within
the water the body stared at the sub and
moved attempting to grab onto the
vehicle the d-class swore they were
trying to say something mouthing words
to the camera of the sub as the sub
passed through the mass of bodies it
emerged into a completely dark black
clearing at the bottom of the pit for a
second the d-class thought he was safe
but then a large black tentacle rapidly
emerged from below and grabbed onto the
nautilus dragging it even further into
the depths the d-class screamed and
panicked but there was nothing he could
do the tentacle possessed a large
cluster of eyes mouths and human heads
seemingly grafted onto its mass and then
there was another tentacle and then
another the nautilus was pulled to the
bottom of the pool the d-class's screams
were still heard even as the picture cut
out sometimes graphic body altering
images of the tentacles features were
visible on the screen but most of the
footage was indecipherable after minutes
of distorted corrupted footage the
nautilus was seen again rapidly
ascending to the surface somehow it had
managed to escape the entity at the
bottom of the pit upon recovery of the
craft it was found that the nautilus was
covered in a thick organic coating
similar to a black slime mold but with
dozens of eyes growing from it the
d-class inside showed severe
psychological damage and attempted to
harm foundation personnel they were
terminated shortly after due to being a
danger to those around them following
review of the footage the nautilus was
to be dismantled and incinerated along
with the remains of the d-class a
reinforced containment seal was fitted
over the pit with the intention of
keeping whatever was down there isolated
from the surface but this was
short-lived after the containment seal
was fitted site 40 underwent a massive
communications blackout every device on
site received an email containing a
single image of a large eye taken from a
security camera the text beneath it
simply read found you some personnel who
viewed the email underwent anomalous
changes growing new physical features
such as eyes and other various growths
across their body the entirety of site
40-r went offline and the foundation
could not establish contact in an
emergency effort to do so mobile task
force gamma-6 deep feeders was sent to
investigate the task force's assault on
site 40-r was a daring effort as the
majority of the site was completely
overtaken by tentacles growths and
anomalous alterations while numerous
altered personnel were lost due to the
mission it was ultimately a success some
altered personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove
their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed without
incident following the site's repair
there has been little activity from the
entity within the pit but the foundation
continued to keep an eye on the creature
and the ecosystem of the anomalous
marine life that live on the bass strait
never knowing what their next move might
be and always keeping in mind the risk
that comes with dealing with these
poorly understood entities now go check
out scp-3000 anatashia and
scp-057-it under the sea for more
anomalous entities living breathing and
thriving in the depths of the unknown